I want to talk a little bit about
lobbyists and draining the swamp or
maybe it's filling the swamp you might
remember this very highly publicized
executive order that President Trump
issued in January weakening Obama era
ethics policies which would allow
lobbyists to work at agencies that they
had sought to influence the Trump order
did limit what lobbyists would be
allowed to do once they enter government
for example directly handling issues on
which they had lobbied it seems sort of
like maybe an on paper victory of sorts
drain the swamp blah blah blah but it
already appears that the Trump
administration is ignoring it ProPublica
found that three new Trump hires are
working on the same issues for which
they lobbied starting with shahira night
Donald Trump's special assistant for tax
and retirement policy she lobbied the
government on tax issues for the
fidelity of for fidelity of financial
services giant the Trump executive order
says that former lobbyists cannot work
in the quote specific issue area in
which they lobbied that phrase isn't
defined she lobbied on tax and
retirement issues and is now working as
Donald Trump's assistant on tax and
retirement issues you also have Michael
Catanzaro and George David banks both
named to the National Economic Council
director Gary cones senior staff what
was what was their background well
Catanzaro was lobbying on fuel standards
and greenhouse gas regulations for the
American fuel & petrochemical
manufacturers he is now special
assistant to the president for domestic
energy and environmental policy sounds
pretty related to me banks recently
lobbied on environmental issues for a
business group he is now special
assistant to the president for
international energy and environment yet
again something publicly said the truth
of what's going on at the White House
and in all these departments is the
opposite of what was publicly said yes
I'm saying because Donald Trump marketed
himself as a
outsider and someone who can fix
Washington and drain the swamp yeah and
I think it's going to make people kind
of upset with the political system and
not really be able to trust another
candidate again to break up Washington
but we know the Donald Trump never
really gave any proposals as to and
citizens united as we know it of course
and it just seems like he wanted to
change the system so he could get
elected himself even drain the swamp
people ate it up without question like
it was the best thing trump admitted
that drain the swamp was bogus he
actually a video where he admitted that
he just kept saying it because people
were reacting positively but he never
even liked the whole thing we're going
to drain the swamp of corruption in
Washington DC funny how that term caught
on is there yeah I tell I tell her I
hated it right we'd like it drain the
swamp I said oh that's so hokey that is
so terrible I said all right I'll try it
so like a month ago I said drain the
swamp place went crazy say whoa what
since then I said it again then I
started saying it like I meant it right
and then I said it such loving it right
I'm figuring out that Donald Trump
speaks in code and I'm starting to get
the the I'm starting to decipher the
code when Trump said he was going to run
the country like a business what he
meant was he wasn't going to follow any
of the rules including the ones he sets
that actually is something that makes
sense to me stunningly a lot of people
are not aware of that video he didn't
even want to do the whole drain the
swamp thing he's admitting he just did
it cuz people reacted to it